what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday july the 5th
happy fourth of july i hope you [__]
i don't know
i hope you [__] lit some firecrackers
or whatever anyway
the reason we're here today we got a
fantastic podcast but before we start it
the joint is brought to you by and i
want to welcome bowling branch to the
show
there's nothing more important than a
good night's sleep bowling branch
knows how to taste more than just a good
matches
you gotta have nice sheets bowling brand
sent me some
sheets let me tell you something me and
my wife you know it was [__] 90
degrees last week it was hotter than
hell
we just used the sheets that's it to
cover them
they were ultra soft nice and long i
could put the [__] sheet over my head
and cover myself
they have 100 organic and they were
comfortable as hell i asked her last
night honey what'd you think of the
[__] sheets
she goes i think they were great i go
yeah i got them on the podcast monday i
wanted to make sure that you like them
too
check out the signature hem sheets
they're the best sellers for a good
reason they get softer with every wash
these sheets are celery buttery soft and
lightweight
they're perfect for all seasons they
come in a variety of colors and every
size from twin
up to california king and here's
something to else to help you sleep
bowling brand sheets are made by
craftsmen who earn a fair living wage
these workers earn
the pay and respect they deserve all
ball and branch products are made
using safe and fair conditions
all right now do me a favor for today
i want you to just go to
bowlandbranch.com
get ready for this the bowling branch
guarantee
enjoy any product worry free for 30
nights
you don't like it to experience the best
sheets you've ever felt
choose bowling branch you can try them
worry free
for 30 nights with free shipping in
return
the joint family gets an exclusive
fifteen percent off your first set of
sheets
with promo code joey at
bowlandbranch.com
b-o-l-l and
branch.com that's bowlingbranch.com
promo code joey i'm not one for sheets
but let me tell you something you're
gonna have to go to weddings you're
gonna have to go to parties maybe your
grandparents
these are a perfect gift and when i
tried them they were a great
phenomenal fit so go to
bowlingbranch.com
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion listen when it comes to cbd who the
[__] do you think you're dealing with
let me give you a little story
i went i became friends with this family
my wife the kids
they're all friends she said cbd got her
sick i said that let me show
them simply see your cbd she showed me
what she was taking
i gave her some [__] thousand
milligrams cbd lion
i saw about [__] five days ago she
told me that was the real [__] deal
that her elbow didn't work that elbow
didn't hurt anymore
that she's sleeping better listen cbd
lion is the best this ain't no [__]
gas station cbd
do me a favor go to cbd lion and read
that third party lab results you see
something you like
go to the link listen they got
kinesiology tape the roll on
the extra strength thousand milligram
cream they got the hemp flour they got
the capsules
they got bath balls i mean what else i
got to tell you
go grab your balls instead of the bath
balls go to cbd lion
press code joe of your church get 20
off and that's how you're gonna do it
okay
and here i'm gonna [__] really hit
you with one from the heart of
[__] new jersey
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings
this saturday you got mcgregor versus
poirier
iii for ufc 264. draftkings has a
[__] slamming offer for you
you ready for this they're going to give
you 264 to 1 odds
if either fight gets a knockout in the
first round
so if dustin knocks out mcgregor
you win 264 and if mcgregor does
knocks out poirier you went through 64.
it slides out either way in round one
you walk away with cash these guys are
one and one and the first time the first
time mcgregor knocked out fourier in the
first round
the second time poirier tko mcgregor in
the in the
second round so this time the guys
aren't playing around
don't worry if mma isn't for you
draftkings has great odds
um promotions like nba basketball finals
the hockey they're in the [__] uh
stanley cup
finals and so much more draftkings are
safe
secure and reliable withdraw your money
when you want to
whenever the [__] you want but it all
starts by you
downloading the top-rated draftkings
sportsbook app
right now today use promo code joy when
you sign up
to turn a dollar into 264 when you bet
on the main event fighter to win
by first round knockout that's promo
code joey to turn a dollar
into 264. uncle joey's trying to [__]
help you here guys
only a draftking sportsbook app right
now
here's the fine print you got to be 21
or older new jersey indiana or
pennsylvania only
new customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gamer problem you
one got hundred and gambler but if
you're in indiana call 9800 with it
but if we're straight and then you know
you know how to bet and you're
controlled listen do me a favor
download the drive king sportsbook app
now and let's win some [__] guitars
it's fourth of july weekend week you
know you blew your money on your
firecrackers
it's time to make some [__] dough and
let's get this [__] joint started
right
who's better than draftkings nobody use
code joey
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's a beautiful day to be alive
it's monday the 5th holy [__]
i hope you had a great fourth of july i
did
friday night we went to eat at some
[__] uh japanese place
with a couple of families saturday we
[__] uh
went to big play zone and we went to a
little party and then [__] sunday was
tremendous
but guess what we're back here mondays
no [__] games
no [__] stories no dramas today we're
going right for something
i don't know if you guys noticed last
week on twitter
somebody put a picture of me and leah
and they said that they had uh
moved on from the church and uh
you know started listening to the joint
again but
that they were proud of me and lee that
look at the changes that we had made
you know that i looked a lot better
you know he looked a lot better we both
sounded happier we both made changes
that nobody knew would happen
listen it was very hard for me
to tell lee that i wanted to stop doing
the podcast it really
bothered the [__] out of me for a long
time i never
spoke about it but i thought it was time
for lee
to move on i had had this kid
working for me for eight years um
i could see that i wasn't happy i didn't
know at the time because listen man
you you never know you're living in hell
you never know that's the name of these
two episodes yeah
you don't know until you don't know
you're in hell until you live it
you know i've been in hell three [__]
times when uh
before i went to prison that addiction i
had
the hell i had in my first marriage
and the [__] hell i had uh
the last four years of living in l.a i
didn't i didn't know it was affecting me
as much as it did
but once i landed here i noticed that
you know how unnormal i was and how
unnormal i felt i felt like
when i first got out of jail you know
like you feel like you don't [__]
belong
but today monday the 5th i feel a lot
[__] better you know it's fight week
we got a great [__] week it's a short
week a lot of years are off today
my daughter starts camp [__] tuesday
finally
till three o'clock i got a [__] life
again you know last week was ccd camp
so she was home at 12 so from [__] 12
to six
i'm johnny entertainer i'm [__] sore
i had to swim
i threw softballs i got hit in the ear
with a [__] softball i don't
you know it's the life of a dad and i'm
enjoying it i'm not complaining about
and it was great
but uh today we have a guest i know it's
monday and you're like joey it's hybrid
we want you
[__] it we got a guest and the guest's
name
is a two-part interview it's today and
wednesday so knock yourself out
we're gonna cover all the things you
wanted to talk about our guest today is
the world
famous the man from outer space
mr lee syed i hope you enjoy this and
i'll talk to you afterwards stay black
what's up [__] how's it going
buddy it's going great man woke up
[__] great slept late today oh yeah
got up at four in the morning i told you
lee
how [__] up did i sound the night on
325 milligrams
i thought you weren't telling anybody
anybody about that yeah you feel you
sounded
it's always when you get real quiet you
start whispering like oh man i'm [__]
up
but then you start giggling that's funny
listen man it's
just tremendous to drop your tolerance
okay i remember eating four of those
[__] things and nothing happened four
one hundreds
or four two hundreds and nothing would
happen and you were putting that what
would that like wax
uh needle thing in there that was 987.
i did that like four times and i'm like
i'm gonna [__] die
i thought i thought you're doing that
every night and then the tea was
medicated too wasn't it was he's
medicated
i didn't drink that last night i gave
that a breather last night
i just took three capsules i drank a
little bit of [__] uh
uh melatonin from on it and i did my
three
capsules from uh magnesium and i [__]
i got up at 4 11 to pee and [__] next
thing you know
i'm like holy [__] i'm [__] stoned
wow yes that's i never understood that
man because we would do those things
and i would be high most of the next day
and you would wake up at six like i'm at
the gym already i'm doing like it didn't
affect you
i had no idea how you wouldn't i would
wake up still high
all the time and i had no idea how you
didn't wake up high
well you know when i wake up high when i
make a mistake in my [__] tweet
like i write something wrong you don't
know how many times i've tweeted and
i go back to look and i'm like i forgot
to eat in that
like i really forget [__] it oh i wake
up
sometimes i wake up so [__] stoned
like not lately but when we were doing
the podcast i wouldn't know what the
[__] i wrote on that till lunch time i'm
like what the
why are people going crazy oh you wrote
about you know
obama's wife [__] or something i don't
[__] know that's how i was getting
i would just giggle and [__] like that
and [__]
tweet lately what i do here is i get up
i get a cup of coffee and instead of
going right to my desk
i go outside okay so you wake up a
little bit
i look at the trees i breathe i look at
the woodpecker
you know some [__] woodpeckers out
there like i'm dying to [__] shoot
him with a bow and arrow but
i'm surprised you haven't yet you know
what he's it's nature what am i going to
do i can't kill everything this
leave a little edible form see what
happens to the squirrels
that's not a bad idea one of those
[__] 100 they're hard to blow
up but then
every time a dead animal's around here i
got like [__] hawks
all around there i told you the chinese
lady across the street great people
great people they got a french poodle
okay and one night
the girl came out with a french poodle
she had the hot pants on i'm on the
balcony
with the [__] rocking chair you know
just watching her
and all of a sudden she looks on the
roof and there's three of those [__]
buzzard
birds that just eat dead [__] right they
were all over they were like on her roof
making noises
and they were on the trees across the
street and she kept looking at the trees
and she kept looking at the [__] at
the house and then she looked at me and
i'm like you better run
because those birds will pick that
[__] french poodle up
and bring him back to taiwan wherever
the [__] he's from
dog that [__] ran in brought the dog in
and then she came out with a mother and
father
and they were looking at eagles then
they crossed the street and they ask me
what they want i go they're buzzing
whatever they just he's [__] dead
birds and dead elk
you know you see [__] dead elk here
oh yeah have you had anyone yet have you
hit a deer yet
no thank god i saw one the other day up
close and personal with his 3d
eyes right next to me in the [__]
light he was right there i'm like what
the [__] are you doing here we waiting
for a light go
jesus my daughter's like daddy's right
there no
there's a street that they always pop
out on and i'm real
you know i do 10 miles an hour and you
know
uh i take my time but there's every
[__] animal here
are there turkeys there's turkeys by
where i live in there there's turkeys
they're disgusting i hate it on the way
to cult snack you see people with
[__]
gigantic turkeys last night i saw two
goats
what yeah the guy just let his goats out
in front of the [__] house i went to
i went to eat japanese food with some
families uh friday night and on the way
back me and my daughter like what the
[__] are those
who would leave their dogs out this
close to [__] the road that's like
heavy duty
and when i got up close and personal it
was two billy goats just eating their
[__] stuff
and i told my wife and she's like i know
there's a guy around the house that's
got chickens
i find out this [__] [__] got
chickens that's easy pickings for me
oh yeah that means i'll sacrifice one a
week i'll take a
buzzard and [__] sacrifice them next
you know i'm betting the yankees i don't
give a [__] jack
save one for me that's what jews do have
has already told you about that
yeah i've seen it it's young kapoor yeah
wave it around by the wave it around
sure oh yeah they won for me last night
i thought about you
when you called right after i hung up
with you there was a thing on tv
just the channel jewish
national news and i'm like what can they
possibly be shown
like just 10 jews beating up a
palestinian like the weather and
who gives a [__] about the weather in
israel i want to see the [__] action
i want to see some rocks
i want to see some [__] people shout
shooting people
explosions people rubbing the wall of
jesus and fainting
you know that i didn't even know about
that it was on tv
yeah it's i guess it's on every [__]
night jewish news
i don't think you're supposed to know
about that i think you might have tapped
into some like secret stuff that i don't
even know about like expressvpn
they think they think you're a jew in
jerusalem now
so on thursday somebody tweeted
that they uh and i know you saw it
and it made you feel really good because
it made me feel really good
somebody tweeted that they were a little
absurd
upset with us when the church ended but
to look back at us now and what we've
done that it made it all worthwhile
and they support the both of us how did
that make you feel
you know what man my life didn't really
change that much in la
it did a little bit i got to do some
cool things meet some cool people hang
out with you
but i wasn't really surrounded
by our our listeners as much like
i lived a pretty the same life
but to the outpouring of love that you
and i have both gotten
over the past god it's almost been a
year uh
has just been amazing i would it would
have
it would have been very different if we
had ended it and they'd like we'll [__]
those guys and
my twitter follower goes to zero and no
one says anything it's
people to this day still send me
messages and half of them are
when are you gonna get the far in the
face but the other half are hey like i
got one the other the other week it was
some guy his wife was having
surgery and he he made it through the
surgery by listening to our podcast and
it doesn't really make sense to me
like i'm i was a chubby guy getting high
on the internet
and it was i had a great time doing it
but the fact that it's like so important
to some people
is just amazing i don't think it doesn't
i don't even really feel like it's
fully clicked in yet i mean we did 800
episodes you got to figure
them 400 of them were good 200
when inebriated at least 200 of them we
didn't know what the [__] was going on
like i don't remember what happened with
the guitar player from the foo fighters
oh i don't remember a guy you know it
was just so many of them
you know we started in the office and
right away my wife told me that we had
to get out because mercy was getting
born
right then we took it to your office and
that's where
you know they let the people know
when the weed thing started in l.a all
these [__] jerk-offs
jumped on the weed bag and wagon like
that they had been smoking weed like
they were friends with tommy chung for
the last 20 years none of these
[__]
these guys were getting high on a
[__] roach and walking around with
make-believe little [__] eyes like
they had smoked and [__]
right nothing bothered me more than that
so i wanted to prove a point
that nobody smoked dope like we did
listen i've been i was smoking chocolate
thai in 1987 getting shipped to me to
boulder
my tolerance has never you know first
off i have an outrageous tolerance as
lee got the
witness and we built it and built it and
built it
and now i knocked it down the 75 sleepy
time
abx [__] uh edibles you know but
that's not the point the point was we
built it up
that we wanted to let everybody know
that no matter what the [__]
[__] you were talking about oh i'm
high
we could out smoke you by top ten
the only [__] that could run
with us will be real that's it
the rest of those [__] were
just front and face
uh you know faking the funk right and we
wanted to prove them wrong
and we won and we did it 2200
milligrams the stars was our [__]
lemonade
i did 3 000 with louis j gomez i mean
that was
when i met you i had smoked weed before
and i had taken edibles once i got so
high in maine ones that i
often only every time i had a homemade
brownie i set my chair
up like an inch outside of where the
umbrella was and i got so sunburned i
turned purple
but like when i first met you dude
mercy wasn't even a thought and you had
me come over to your office and you had
that little tiny mini bong
and you used to put ice cubes in it and
i would take little hits
and i started getting like real proud of
myself i was taking okay hits
and then that one day that you put hash
in it but didn't tell me like that was
the turn
that was the turning point because you
put that hash in it and i took a weed
hit and my lungs exploded
and remember my face turned real red
like that box behind you that book
and from there man we had we had to give
you a can of coke
oh yeah we every you took me to like a
barbecue place
but then like from there like we
outlasted
probably six edible companies we had
the cookies with the frosting we had
auntie dolores
which the cookies with the frosting were
200 milligrams
and i would tell you there were 100
milligrams
and he would heat the whole thing and
then we'd have an extra one
and we'd get so high that we needed
munchies and we'd split another cookie
and eat it as a [__] munchie i mean
we weren't [__] around so
the whole time lee thought he was in
[__] inhaling uh
uh 25 25 milligrams and then i was
taking the chiba chews
the 180s and taking them out and putting
them in a 60 milligram wrapper
and i would even leave mine open and put
to lea and he goes i don't trust that
one that's the one i want the other one
he would actually pick the 180
and i would take the 60 and i would just
be sitting there like
he's falling for these [__] street
tricks
it was [__] tremendous oh i had no
idea i had people emailing me you should
sue joey this isn't right
and like like what about the time and
this one like i was the only one like
you like played these games with
the first time you ever my dad ever came
out to la
you you guys got along great and you're
like before you take him to the airport
come and see me and he gave him a
chocolate chip cookie
and you even told him he said eat half
he got nervous before he went to
security ate the whole thing
they he fell asleep on the airplane they
had to walk into his car and he got
pulled over on 95 doing like 30 miles an
hour
like you you [__] up you loved [__]
up my dad you loved [__] up
like everybody like you like the the
yoshi story
you would [__] up people look at tom
segura he had to get an
uber home from the valley one time and
just park his car to ralph's
like people they had no idea the edibles
that we were doing
and that's i used to get a lot of
messages like you're such a [__] you
should take
like how can you not handle these
edibles like most people
you said you were [__] on yourself
like oh i have such a low tolerance
at 75. most people take 75 now
and they're on the moon like they don't
know what's going on
so the fact that you can still do 75 is
still all like
we shouldn't have been doing to that we
did 2 000
adam as a minimum for like at least a
year i think
twice a week my i would take craps and
my poops would smell like gummies
because you'd have to eat 10 of them
tell them what the guy that's used to
give us the stars at that
tell these people what the guy looked
like oh jesus
he he looked like he had been
like he looked like he was straight out
of like i know you don't like the show
that much but like breaking bad like
his face was messed up he had like long
hair he like
for those of you who don't know when it
was medical like this guy was making
them in his kitchen
it wasn't like a high it wasn't like a
real deal operation
this guy had like a like a cookie cutter
and he was just making gummies
and [__] like it was it was it's not
like it was basically a legal drug deal
i like it it was not at all like there
was like there was no real packaging it
was like a ziploc bag
with a label that he printed out on his
computer and put it on it like it wasn't
like now they have like actual like pill
bottles and it looks nice
like this was i i i missed i never i
don't think i ever tried the uh
the breath mints the the strips that you
had
i i came in after that but for a while
like they were people were just giving
us stuff like those gummies hermanos
guys
were probably the craziest they drove
down from northern california a six-hour
drive
with a a dab torch in the cup holder
doing dabs people had no idea what we
were up against
oh my god remember that time at the
improv we did that on the side of the
street
i did a dab at the improv melrose improv
on melrose boulevard
yeah but i thought my [__] lungs were
gonna blow up i'm like i enjoy smoking
weed but this
is the next level of reefer which i'm
not ready for i can't show up at the
house with a [__] blow torch
there's no way my wife will lose her
[__] mind she sees a blow torch
we got so high we left the the bong in
the office bathroom like three times and
they just throw it out and then the
ladies
imagine if you just left the torch out
because you just forgot about it like no
that
i i'm surprised we didn't blow that
office up at the end
i'm really surprised that office just
didn't [__] blow up from
when we got out of there
i found [__] behind the refrigerator
from i mean you know people would come
drop
off pills that we would never eat you
know
i mean we ate those happy pills for a
while god knows what they were from our
friend in vegas
oh god but going back to the star guy i
was thinking about him the other day
to me that guy looked like because he
was jewish
i didn't know that he didn't really know
did he join you no because hitler beat
the [__] out of him during the holocaust
and hitler was the one that taught him
how to make those stars at that and he
told them
you know i mean the guy was beat the
[__]
to death yeah he looked like a bomb hit
him and god knows
what was in those edibles you know i
always buy the liver cleaner
okay i take medication and you want
so i would do cycles of liver cleanse
you know just for a couple weeks just to
get all that
you know that jell-o those jell-o things
that means it's got certain with it
that's what holds the jell-o together
and serto
is what you used to take to clean your
piss test oh jesus why don't you
tell me about these liver cleanse things
because you know
i don't have the time you know i'm
saying when you when you're deep in 2000
milligrams
things slip your mind i guess so
oh my god yeah that was dude we took
everything we took
cat tranquilizers one time the ketamine
oh gee i i don't know blood yeah we told
everybody the best was the kid who said
there's hidden footage of you guys
snorting blow
oh jesus we never did blow in that
[__] office no
i know two people who did it not in the
office in the bathroom
yeah but we know people who did [__]
blow on the show but we never did blow
on the show
then we had the beautiful night of doing
the acid podcast that destroyed the
internet for a week
you know ari went to australia three
weeks after that
and he said that there was a long line
at the airport not the hotel to check in
right and a guy saw him and came from
behind and said
mr shafil let me take you into this room
and he took ari into the room he's like
i wonder what this is the guy checked
him out
papa gave him free wi-fi internet 15
a day you know the whole thing and he
goes let me walk you up to your room and
now he's like
this is getting creepy you know why is
this guy walking me up to my room
and the next thing you know the guy
opens the door puts hari's
luggage down hari tips him and the guy
goes i loved you on the ass at church
and he go
all the way in australia that it was
wild where it went but like
the thing about that one and all all the
time
we got high that i don't know if people
know is we got high like
and like we would sometimes sit there
for an hour before we started
people had no idea by the time by the
time we started we were
[__] up like i remember i still
remember the acid church
we met at your house your wife made
cuban steak sandwiches
we took the acid and then we went to the
office we probably took
no you yeah you did you had me take
edibles and bong hits to calm the acid
down i'm still not even sure if that's a
real thing or we just want to be more
[__] up
but it was like that one and and the
best part of that
was duncan at the end sending that video
where i think we laughed for like
30 minutes straight just off of that
video of that guy dancing around
flipping his dick around with his hands
like that and he was like a transsexual
or something he had like a [__] hair
but a dick was in there somewhere and he
just got stripped naked the thing about
that night was
what i tell people all the time acid
is a non-planned event
you never plant acid acid somebody comes
over and you're like mike what's going
on nothing
i got no work tomorrow right [__] let's
do some ass what do we mean
what are we gonna do just let the
universe take you
and that night the universe took us i
mean
ari took his shirt off oh he laid down
he laid down for a while
and then the killer was you know when
duncan sent the text of the guy dancing
naked and we [__] lost it but the
best one
i just i looked at my phone i never did
it before
and i just masked emailed everybody i
just masked email everybody had to be
midnight i said i don't give a
[__] and there was only one person who
said something to me rogan rogan was
like where the [__] was that i can't
have that on my phone
he nearly died when he saw that little
there's some little mexican guy from
narcos
he comes out with some mexican music on
he just started stripping himself
and when he pulled his pants out he had
a bush he had more head on his [__]
dick than i got on my hair
yeah and he had like i don't know it was
like a [__] and a dick coming out of it
like it was like a combo
package you know right it made me feel
good about my dick but like yeah
yeah that's uh something else i don't
know if we've talked about is
you have a no texting rule but when you
text
it's gonna be fun i can't tell you how
many times i woke up at seven in the
morning
to a text from you of just the most
outrageous piece of [__] like like like
the longest [__]
you would just say it wasn't no words
either just a piece of [__] and it would
pop in my
like seven in the morning you text you
it's like and it's hysterical
but like you text the craziest [__] you
text that and he checks food
every time you go back to jersey you
text me like pieces of pizza
or the egg roll at chan's like you you
text some crazy [__]
i text big shits to you segura and bert
christian segura got the biggest kick
out of him
you can't text the [__] picture on
twitter because then you'll get
22 000 back for weeks every time you
open up a twitter you think like it's
happy birthday
it's a big piece of [__] with [__] all
over the toilet you can't do it on the
instagram or anything like that
no you can't do each other i would send
them to [__] tom and tom would
actually look at it
enlarge it oh and go what the [__] it's
it's 22 inches what did you eat you know
tom would it would really mess with toms
and sides like what
why would you send me this now i got to
take a [__] to match it you know what
what am i gonna do
i mean it was just people have no idea
the the craziness
that was going on then we after lee's
apartment
we moved into an office in like a
horrible part of town
oh yeah didn't you hit somebody with
your like car door at the 7-eleven
that 7-11 was guys it was
[__] real there was a 7-eleven
on magnolia and whatever
over lankershim passed lancashire past
life what was our street
not cumston kuanga maybe gawanga it was
koenga and
there was a 7-eleven there that you know
had his moments
from time to time a hindu got hit you
know a homeless guy would throw a bottle
of [__] milk at him or something
then you had the low you had the laurel
canyon
7-eleven which was [__] isis
every time you went in there they had
the turbans on they really did
music on after eight minutes you'd be
[__] saying jihad because they
they would play the music out loud like
you would be in there going next thing
you know you're dancing
jihad he had [__] america and then they
killed the owner
yeah they killed the [__] nona the isis
people right in front they stabbed
them to death right in front of the
laundromat not ah people you got to be
in on this [__] to believe it but then
there was another 7-eleven on burbank
and some street it was in burbank we
rented an
office there yeah that's burbank and
quinga banking coin it was a dump
the office was a dump oh yeah had no
windows
no ac no ac the table and we had a
an african-american accountant next to
us so a consultant
not even that it was uh what do you get
a notary a traveling notary republic
[__] hated us from day one of us from
day one we were
and we like made there was no window so
we couldn't smoke weed in there
and we didn't we never smoked we smoked
a vapor pipe that you can't smell
and we have felipe in there one day and
next thing you know
she's banging on the [__] wall if you
listen to the felipe episode
she's banging on the wall we're [__]
ignoring her we're laughing their asses
off
then we were in there and there was an
earthquake with rick ramos
oh jesus i forgot about that the
earthquake were rick ramos when we were
in there and we just stopped that was a
tremendous podcast moment
we had my god my uncle in there yeah we
did
with jerry roach yeah and then we took
over
then we found then we were going to move
out to like
[__] the barbecue place all the way
out there in north hollywood and
right that was just a dump the guy's
like i walked in there i was dead three
minutes and i'm drenched with sweat
and i go what's up with the air
conditioner the guy goes it's on
i go yeah it's [__] crazy what is it
that he goes 78 what normal people put
it on i'm not in my house
no my shit's at 52. this penguin's
[__] running around the house the
vent the whole [__] thing
but then i did a podcast for dre great
dre great
great drake oh but you're forgetting an
office which one
you're forgetting the one on next to the
in and out where the homeless guy was
in the hallway sleeping and that was a
good office
that was a very good office a little
creepy we're about to get killed
yeah because when you left there it was
[__] scary it was just dark
but that was a fun one because we would
do the periscope on the stairs
yep we would put away two [__] joints
oh and yeah oh and there was like an uh
an acting school downstairs there was a
lot of weird [__] in that office but
they didn't mess with us there was
actually we found out a weed delivery
company also in that
in that building right at the end that
that was right before we were gonna move
but that office
that's where we had angel salazar that's
where we had stephen bower and we had uh
dennis hoff dennis hoff with his
assistant [__] the rapist with the
harmonica
when he kept playing the [__]
harmonica and you would freak out
and then uh i don't know what made this
move there from there
uh didn't the other one become available
or something
right over the holidays like january i
i had mercy and i took it to the park
and my wife was like bring it back in an
hour and i'm like what the [__] we gonna
do back in the house in an
hour so i kept her in the park all
[__] morning i went to 7-eleven i got
us hot dogs and [__]
and i got her an ice cream and as we
were walking back
the guy came out and he goes hey you're
still interested in office
we have one available on the second
floor and i was [__] blown away
you know he goes we it's going to take a
week because we got to get the caskets
out of there i go what [__] caskets
because across the street was a funeral
paul and they were using it
as a casket place i didn't know that
jesus christ
i didn't know the caskets were being
stored in there yeah there were caskets
in there what are you [__] nuts and
that was
the final office we were in there for
four years and it was
just tremendous that office was uh
i still remember breaking the walls down
how painful it was
you know it was it was kind of not bueno
but
you know lee we did the eight years you
got the [__] uh
lisa yet and out of space which
hopefully someday you'll turn into an
nft and you're just going back
oh i have that's coming and uh
it was just really weird how did you
feel when i came to you that day and
said
because it was about a year ago it was
about a year ago
that i said you know
i think it's time for us to end this how
did you feel at first
well i wouldn't have stayed in la
nearly as long as i did if it wasn't for
the podcast i didn't like it i missed
some people in la
and i missed the weather right now but i
didn't i never liked la
um there's always gonna be a little bit
of sadness
um but it wasn't it wasn't really out of
the blue you'd been talking about
leaving
for like three or four years it felt
like at least like no no like
nailed down time but you know
i owe it wherever you because i i've
said this for months and people ask
i honestly feel like our relationship is
better now
yes um i feel like
it it's good because i mean you've seen
tv shows podcasts anything go on for too
long
and that wouldn't like that would hurt
um i had a great time doing it
i i i miss you
but it it it is kind of weird
i'm not i'm not a very religious person
but if you look at it
we started the podcast the first week of
september 2012
and ended the last week of august of
like exactly eight years and
we like and i even told you i was like
hey man like i
i don't want i just want us to be cool
after this
like i would have hated if like i moved
to new jersey and then there was a blow
up or
or i didn't like new jersey or whatever
and then we didn't talk
so i like it almost worked
perfectly like it as much as i
like it was a blast and it was a great
time
it almost worked you couldn't have
written it better almost
you know lee i felt
[Music]
after the netflix thing on the way home
from vegas
that was a very cold reality for me
that in this life it's better to want
than to have like all i remember
and i don't give a [__] who gets angry
about this
all i remember is being on a date with
my wife at the cuban joint el cochinito
in silver lake
and getting the call from my manager at
the time
that netflix offered me a half hour i
mean it's april
18th or something it's the end of
[__] april
or it's the end of may and they're
talking about
a july shooting and i'm like
even though it's a half hour that's just
not enough that's a recipe
for destruction but
i gotta be honest with you the netflix
and the whole thing
overtook me i was blinded by it i'm
smart enough to say it today
and i agreed to it then when they told
me it was in a [__] pool
i'm like what the [__] there's not
enough stages in vegas like the whole
thing was such a bad experience for me
that the experience bled into everything
else
like because that manager bled into my
comedy and he was a great guy i'm not
saying nothing he was just doing his job
but that whole period taught me it's
better to want
than to have i i i don't want to do this
if it's going to be to
you know my phone rang constantly
you know i had made a mistake and given
my phone number to podcast people
and they wanted something every day
every day except for guys like bob
lolingis and berg and
you know i was getting calls that i
don't need these calls
right i don't need these calls this is
taking time from my family
it's taken time from my friends and it's
taken its toll on me this stupidity
and you have to be nice you try to be
nice
but it was just too much there was so
much
going on that people had no idea
mike comes over we do a podcast
he's gone in an hour and a half two
hours with us
it was six hours oh it was nice with
ralphie we got there
ralphie would get there an hour late
and then we would stay there till two in
the morning and then you had to put the
podcast together till five and
it was it was a job that was went from
being
it was supposed to be five hours a week
tops
to 16 hours and i got stand up and i got
writing and i got touring and i got
and then what about booking well like
that's something that people don't know
about podcasts
is you have to a book it and then b how
many times
we get to the office and then you get a
call hey man i can't make it
like it it happened a lot
and it's it's not it's like the least
fun part about podcasting
i think you know we're probably going to
do this in two parts
okay um
that was the thing that wore me the most
because
we're gonna tell people what a lot of
people didn't [__] know
how many times did people do a podcast
we did a good job with them we got it
done
and they never called again people knew
you paid to come out
i'm not gonna drop names on here and
throw people under the bus and make
people feel bad because it's not what we
do but
it was really hard on you that you
take care of somebody you put them in a
hotel room
you do all these things and then they
tell you to go [__] themselves afterward
and it happened with
a couple of people i just saw a guy
online like holy [__] him and i used to
talk
every three days and one day he just
decided that
i asked him what he had done the night
before that he was supposed to meet me
what happened i didn't ask him in a
weird or in a
in an angry way i just asked him in a
you know
and he cut me my friendship off there
was ten of those guys
then you had the people that would reach
out to you a week before
on monday and go hey man do you mind if
i come on your podcast and
you and i would get all excited this
person's coming on the podcast
and you don't hear from them and three
days later you throw on twitter and
there he is on joe rogan
right so they would use us as leverage
and then when uh rogan put and i'm not
mad at joe at all for this joe didn't
even know it was happening
you know i didn't know was happening i
never mentioned it to him i didn't need
to he he's my friend i mean he's gotten
that
but it showed us what people were the
desperate people
it showed us uh the level of people
you mentioned the name you know yoshi
i know yoshi from 1995
in seattle i've i forced
the club manager to put him on stage
yoshi would call me every week me and
ari to see what we were doing the show
the guest set you know and we would give
him a guest set
and uh one night you know yoshi's gonna
call in
at six in the morning where we were
making people get up at six in the
morning and
he calls me at 5 45 and says
i don't know if i could do this i just i
just don't feel right doing this i feel
all right yoshi don't worry about it
maybe you're still off on that edible we
gave you two years ago
and the next thing you know he's on
rogan with kenneth cho
the next day i can show whatever again i
wasn't mad
when my feelings a little hurt you know
i know you're 20 [__] years all you
had to say was you were going on rogan
and i wouldn't be [__] mad at you but
that wasn't the [__] case you know no
it's um and then sometimes people would
just
flake and not even call not even call
it you know there was a few times it
wasn't didn't happen as much
but i remember like we waited at the
office once i think for like two hours
for some
i don't even remember who it was but
like we just waited and waited and
waited and they just never showed up
and or like they would come and like i
know you would always get calls like
you tell me like someone told me to talk
to their manager and they wanted to
pre-approve
questions and it's like no yeah
it's it it's ridic and then you would
even tell me
that like getting getting paid for the
podcast for the
for the sponsors was months of work
like it wasn't just it wasn't just us
going to the office and having a good
time like it was
it's honestly a full-time job
just to do that and then you also had
your comedy you had the book you were
writing you had
being a father and we also
something that people i don't think uh
know is
a lot of podcasts take breaks take a
vacation
we didn't start taking christmas off
until like two years before it ended
like we just we just went straight
every week two episodes a week i don't
think we missed a week
i don't i literally don't think we
missed a week
no it was uh and we were doing them
first we started at six in the morning
which was [__] rough because you and
i were getting up in the middle of night
and you were working you were going
straight from a job to that
right and then uh
we [__] you know moved it you gotta
remember monday wednesday
thursday i'm getting up on the 4 a.m
flight to go to city city
friday i'm getting up to do [__]
radio and then sunday i'm sleeping three
hours
to [__] make the 6 a.m flight back to
l.a
i was gaining weight my [__] sleep
was terrible you know my blood pressure
was always running high
and i didn't have a [__] clue what
the [__] was bothering me
you know something was eating away at me
but it didn't really dawn on me
this whole thing didn't dawn on me what
we were doing
until you started going to therapy
then it really started
to [__] bother me when you really it
wasn't about like it wasn't about i
wasn't going there crying about you or
anything
no but just the fact that
i knew that you were unhappy about
something
made me [__] really think
we'll cut it there and we'll save the
rest
for wednesday we'll be right back ladies
and gentlemen we're gonna wrap this up
and part two will come to you on [__]
wednesday
i'll see you then thanks lee thank you
buddy
no no we're going to keep this
conversation going right
straight to [__] uh because this is
where the nuts and bolts of this
conversation comes in i thought we would
get to it before it
but let's leave it there with you
joining therapy all right
okay thank you for coming on and uh
we'll see you in 10 minutes
thank you buddy it was good seeing lee
that was the first part it was really
good [__] seeing lee
and i told you guys that uh he sounds a
lot better
uh he looks better he's happier with his
mom up there
guys listen i have a certain gift
and it's i was taught to me as a young
man
you have to know when to fold the cards
you have to know
i don't care if you have a drug
operation
if you're in it three four years you got
eight million put away
you've never got a [__] indictment
against you you
[__] you know your home life is solid
which
never is because you can't be a [__]
junkie and a father but
if you're doing it as a business and
your kids are happy one day you have to
look and say how much longer can i do
this
until i go down until this business goes
down this industry goes down this error
goes down or better yet i go down
you have to know when it's time to pull
out as painful as it was
this was hard for me i had to leave i
just wasn't canceling a podcast
it was leaving la it was rerouting my
family but you know what
we're here today and today this is uncle
joey's joint
and lee's got his podcast and that's
what
this is all about is evolving and you
guys saw it we didn't tell you a [__]
story
this isn't the stories i used to tell in
the church from 30 [__] years ago
this is what's happening now in front of
your eyes so we're not [__] just
talking to talk
we're walking the [__] walk
[__] don't forget
july 16th out of the ice cream shop
in uh studio city california
laughing gas will be available to you
tremendous therefore i need for you guys
to do me a big favor though
right now i don't need any patreon i
don't need anything i need for you to go
to instagram
and to click on friend [__] at
laughing gas with two g's at the end
laughing gas just friend this we're
gonna have announcements on there
you're gonna know what stores the weed
is gonna be sold on
and uh i tell you what man i tried it
already
31 [__] percent nice it's not too
[__] heavy for a lot of years and
it's just right it's
just right when you smoke it you're a
little hungry you get giggly
you'll think of your uncle joey and
that's it things goes as they are
the nfps will be released this week one
day i'll keep you guys posted on patreon
but that's it i hope you enjoy enjoyed
the list
interview and uh we'll be back wednesday
with part two
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank lisa that's part one
part two is wednesday the seventh so
don't go nowhere
we're gonna continue this talk we're
gonna talk about therapy and everything
else
but before we leave a word from our
sponsors
like i told you in the beginning the
joint is brought to you by bowling
branch there's more
nothing more important than a good
night's sleep and if you
guys i'm preaching sleeping because
that's the [__] toughest thing that
we don't do
and it's the thing that's going to help
us the most bowling branch knows it
takes more than just a good mattress
you got to have nice sheets bowling
brand sheets
are super ultra soft plus they're
organic and sustainably produced
they sent my wife the funny thing was my
fanny called me my agent she goes you
want to look at these sheets i went on
the website i go yeah they look pretty
good
she goes all right i'll have them send
you some [__] the next day they sent
them to me in a box with a rapper
i mean it was tremendous you got a sec
let's check out the signature hem
sheets they're the best sellers for a
good reason they get softer
with every wash these sheets are buttery
soft and lightweight
last week we went to that heat spell
remember it was 90 degrees for three
nights
these sheets came in perfect because
they're perfect for all seasons
they come in a variety of colors and
every size from
twin up to california king and here's
something else to help you sleep
bowling brand sheets are made by
craftsmen who earn a fair living wage
not these other companies that people
are jumping off rules and stuff like
that because they're not getting paid
i ain't mentioning no names
bowlingbranch.com
b-o-l-l and branch dot com
write that down because get ready for
this this is the bowling branch
guarantee
enjoy any product worry free for 30
nights
to experience the best sheets you've
ever felt choose bowling branch you can
try them worry free
for 30 nights which free shipping and
returns
and the joint family gets an exclusive
15 off on the
first set of sheets with promo code joey
at bowl and branch.com listen
i know you're a savage you're like joey
why are you talking to me about sheets
you got parents
you got grandparents you got uncles and
aunts this is a nice gift
you know what i'm saying i'm just
thinking about you people and i'm saving
you 15
off but it all starts by you to go by
going to bowlingbranch.com
b-o-l-l and branch.com
promo code joey go to bowling branch
right now you're gonna love these sheets
comfortable
as hell the joint is also brought to you
by
c b d lion oh
[__] the best listen man
i i use all this stuff you don't see any
more gummy bears do you no
cause i ate them all that's why the ones
with melatonin are [__] delicious all
right
but it all starts with you by going to
cbdlion.com
right now reading the third party lab
results
reading about cbn cby cbd
and how they could benefit you you see
something you like
pressing code joey or church and get 20
off delivered to your
house cbdlion.com
real cbd from your uncle joey i i don't
play
games this is also coming from the uncle
joey
from the heart of new jersey
10th avenue freeze out comes this
saturday
mcgregor versus poirier iii ufc 264
draftkings has a slamming offer for you
joey i don't gamble i i only play ping
pong listen i don't give a [__]
they're giving you 264 to one odds if
either fighter gets knocked out in the
first round do you understand me
now mcgregor knocked them out in the
first round the first fight
in the second fight poirier knocked him
out in the second round
what do you think's going to happen i'm
giving you 264
it's that simple but you got to download
the
draftking sportsbook app right now
like i said he knocked them out the
first time
poor ray knocked him out the second time
this time these guys aren't [__]
playing around
the odds are tremendous better dollar
you walk away with 265
dollars for a dollar are you [__]
crazy
is this something wrong with you go bang
your head against the wall right now
now you think you know everything about
mma so put your money where your [__]
mouth is
and let's win a little [__] guinness
this weekend one dollar
to win 264. and mma isn't for me joey i
don't like that [__]
i don't like it it's two guys with
bikinis on then go [__] yourself
draftkings has great odds on promotions
on basketball
on the finals which is happening right
now as we speak and hockey
and you got some baseball on there and
they got a [__] tremendous casino
draftkings is safe secure reliable you
withdraw your money whenever the hell
you want whenever you
you don't want to gamble i don't want to
gamble no more you know jehovah winston
is knocked on my door okay
take your money out download the drop
the top rated draftking sportsbook app
today
right now use promo code joy when you
sign up
to turn a dollar into 264. how long
you're gonna sit here
and let me give you your beatings on
draftkings today's your [__] day
place your bet watch the fist fly this
weekend
that's promo code joey to turn a dollar
into 264
only at draftkings sportsbook app you
got to be 21 older [__]
go play with the [__] kazoo new
jersey indiana and pennsylvania only
new customers only don't start your [__]
that you join
don't [__] with me i'm trying to make
you 264 dollars
and you want to play [__] tick tock
with me restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details
you got a gambling problem call eight
hundred gambler
or in indiana call one eight hundred
nine with it
now if you don't have a problem and you
just wanna have some fun
download the draftking sports book app
win some [__] guitars
buy some reefer get your wife a new pair
of bikinis and eat that monkey
draftkings.com download the [__]
sports book app right now i love you
[__]
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank bowling branch and i want to thank
cbd lion for being savages
and having our back but i want to thank
you guys and don't forget
we'll be back wednesday with the second
part of the lee siad interview i love
you [__]
happy fourth of july week and enjoy the
rest of your day
i'm stoned i almost forgot
[Music]
foreign
you